talking with Chris and Minnesota hi
Chris we're trying to talk a minute ago
your phone was messing up maybe we got
you now how you doing man good sorry
about that Dave how are you better than
I deserve
sorry about that myself so alright
what's your question sir yes sir keep it
brief and to the point I'm on baby stuff
number two and my question to you as I
work out at the end of you car
dealership
my car's paid off and a lot of the guys
say hey you work in the business you get
a $450 a month lease credit
why don't you lease a BMW and represent
the brand that you work for my response
is I'm getting out of debt and I'm done
with debt that's fine and you could
drive a used Beemer for that matter
they're a great car you don't have to
lease a car to represent the brand
correct but being in the business I
obviously know how the values can change
and I feel like if I got a lease for
$400 a month and my lease credit was 450
I was breaking even essentially exactly
just wanted to get your thoughts you
might you might be okay you don't get
any credit otherwise it just depends on
you know again if if you're driving the
car for free essentially and it's going
down in value and you turn it back in
then you've saved whatever the loss in
value is on that car but if you're
driving a car now that's not going down
in value you're doing the same thing so
don't you I don't like their argument
you have to go do this because you
represent the brand if you have to be
stupid to represent your brand that's
not a good thing okay but if the deal
makes sense then the deal makes sense
and so they give you a $450 credit when
you work in a dealership right and
that's on their traditional lease the
lease that they have for the consumer or
the employee okay no but I mean you you
it's an employee lease and then but the
lease is based on the same way you
calculate it for the consumer only they
give you a $450 credit exactly yeah so
if you took out a $450 a month lease
payment you would drive for free
correct yes that would be put into my
check essentially that money's going to
come out of my check and I just don't
want to and if you do a three-year lease
and after a year they fire you what
happens exactly I would the lease would
still be in my name the payments not
gonna stuff that's what I thought
or if you quit because you got a better
job now you're new now you have a lease
so I wouldn't do it okay
and yeah that's that's what I thought
Dave and I really appreciate it
no I would not would consider at some
point buying a used BMW for cash and
driving it and say I Drive the product
okay because they are a great car they
make a wonderful vehicle and I'd be I
would consider that and some of the car
manufacturers for the manufacturing
folks not the dealership folks have all
kinds of wonderful deals that are
basically a rental program that it's a
month-to-month lease and if you could do
this on a month-to-month basis to where
if you got got fired or quit you're not
stuck with the balance of the lease then
I would probably look at doing it
because some of these deals are really
like Nissan for instance here in our
neighborhood in the Nashville area has a
wonderful program for their for the
plant workers where they get to drive a
car it cost them almost nothing and they
get to drive a car but if they leave
they can just turn it in and they're not
stuck with three more years of payments
or something I mean if you can do
something like that I'm fine with that
I'm okay now that would be alright or if
you want to do a one-year lease and take
a little bit of risk I'd be okay well
considering that but the idea that you
get stuck with something long-term and
they're not paying the bill I'm not I'm
not after that so hope that helps you
ma'am thanks for the call